hola buenos días pues un ambiente muy
extraño que se vive esta mañana aquí en
chile como de conmoción en algunos
sectores de alegría en otros eran los
resultados esperados pero también había
dudas sobre la eficacia de las encuestas
que habían fallado previsiones
electorales de forma muy categórica en
ocasiones anteriores recordemos que este
año ha habido varias elecciones ya en
chile lo que se puede esperar a partir
de ahora es toda una serie de
coaliciones y acuerdos entre los
distintos partidos mientras que el
candidato oficialista así que el ya dijo
que va a conversar con casa para poder
alcanzar acuerdos y que sus votantes que
se vayan hacia hacia la opción de café
la izquierda en general también se
mostró a favor de gabriel boric sobre
todo afirmando que se trata de una
defensa de la democracia casi todos los
partidos se alinearon al lado de boric
salvo la democracia cristiana que
también dijo que tiene que pensar lo que
va a hacer en el futuro que va a
convocar a sus a sus miembros para tomar
una decisión al respecto
ahora patricia hablamos mucho de estas
elecciones presidenciales pero que
pueden reportarnos usted sobre la
composición del senado y también de la
cámara cómo queda entonces el panorama
político en chile
también mucha sorpresa una sorpresa en
este sentido en el senado en la derecha
retiene
un 50% del senado es decir vuelve a
ganar fuerza en la composición
parlamentaria recordemos que según las
elecciones de mayo pasado la derecha
había perdido y no había conseguido
alcanzar un tercio de los votos en la
composición de la nueva
convencional constituyente y se esperaba
que esto pudiera volver a suceder de
alguna forma en el senado no fue así el
senado queda una mitad del senado es de
fuerzas de derecha y la otra mitad es de
fuerzas más o menos de izquierda y hay
un término un componente de un partido
independiente veremos ahí cuál va a ser
el equilibrio de fuerzas también en el
congreso de diputados vemos un congreso
de diputados muy variados donde no se
alcanza
donde hay una mayoría clara y que
obligará a al futuro presidente a tener
que alcanzar acuerdos para lograr
entre las distintas fuerzas para lograr
sacar adelante la legislación